father's day is sunday who is ready to
transform that dad pod into a rad bod we
have the perfect people to help with the
job this is chris schneider he's the
general manager of ufc fit and ryan a
ufc fit trainer welcome you guys how you
doing yeah i'm good besides the physical
benefits of working out what else do
your clients see from from working out
with ufc fit well you know i mean i
think the biggest thing is uh you know
the mental capacity of it right you know
uh so some some very good positive
aspects about mental health um but then
you know also we we know just from basic
science that 2000 steps a day for
anybody reduces heart attack by 25
so it's i mean just get moving is what
we tell everybody get in the gym and get
moving yeah you guys offer classes and
one-on-one training there yeah so i mean
it's very unique in the concept and the
culture we offer boutique style classes
such as kickboxing mma striking
conditioning we even have jiu jitsu
there as well so um it's it's a little
bit of everything under the same roof
for everybody and ryan you're a trainer
and here to show us a couple moves what
are we doing that's right we're going to
grab our kettlebells here you're going
to follow along with me okay chris is
going to kind of cue
your experience you're a fighter are you
yes sir okay yeah don't do that to a ufc
guys knock you out like that okay how
heavy are these kettlebells these are uh
20 kg that's about 44 pounds give or
take let me take this out the beautiful
thing about kettlebells
all right
so we're going to swing this up get into
a rack position
and chris is going to take us through 44
pounds swinging over my head yeah you're
going to scratch it right here just like
yeah just like ryan so get into your
just like right okay okay so rack it up
and there you go yeah
you got it and all you're going to be
doing right now is you're going to do a
standard march position right and just
yep there you go just like that just
warm it up a little bit get in the right
places yeah and then so and what's this
working because i i feel i'm starting to
get winded right so you have core
stability obviously you're applying some
resistance with the kettlebell obviously
the high knees is getting your core
engaged your hip flexors all that fun
stuff right and we're just warming up
right now right and the beautiful thing
about kettlebells is you can grab these
at any local sports store and use these
at home so you don't have to go to the
gym to use them even though i want you
to come to my gym
what's the next thing all right so now
you're going to go into uh what we what
are we saying here i'm just here
switching around squatting press
we're going to go into a squat and press
position so you're going to rack it just
like you had
classes where instructors like ryan are
teaching everyone so we have a duck
class dot stands for daily ultimate
training and that's the class we do
daily so then you're going to keep it in
that position and you're just going to
grab it
so if you can't press it that's okay
just keep staying into your right into
your position try to use your
[Applause]
in uh uh assistance to that is you can
do it with both hands you can go into a
basic squat and then press it with both
both yeah so let's try this okay let's
try that let's give it a so hold it like
that hold it oh no i gotta use the old
two oh i gotta check it out
he
here we go there we go and down and
press it up that's my shirt says coach
on it yes
exactly
but again if these are too heavy we
obviously go lighter or you can do them
with just one kettlebell press it up
with both hands now these are these on
the heavier side they're going here
correct which can you start a five
pounder we have five pounders we have
tens uh it really just depends on you
know obviously they range all the way up
to i think 80 pounds so and how many
locations you guys have in town we have
two locations here in las vegas uh we're
all over the u.s uh but here in las
vegas we're over off of silverado
maryland parkway and then our location
where we're located at is off of the 95
and uh centennial parkway i love it
thank you chris absolutely brian you're
a fighter man thank you so much brother
i appreciate it now let's get on the
ground and grapple come on roman all
right
jillian i'll send it over to you we're
gonna wrestle over here i'm just